انا في منطقه لا ادري اذا كنت استطيع ان
اصفها بانها مخيم لكن هي مجموعه خيان نصبت
واقيمت من قبل الاهالي بين الابنيه
السكنيه المتضرره على اطراف منطقه عفرين
وقبل ان اريكم هذه الخيام اريد فقط ان
نتجه وانتقل بكم الى احد المساجد الذي
تحول الى مركز ايواء يضم عشرات العائلات
وهو بالمناسبه ايضا قد تصدع نتيجه الزلزال
الذي ضرب هذه المنطقه هنا في ريفي عفرين
تشاهدون الان عشرات العوائل التي
سكنت هذا المسجد بعد ان تضررت بيوتها
وتدمرت وعائلات اخرى ايضا
هربت الى هذا المكان خوفا من الهزات
الارتداديه المستمره وقد كانت هنالك هزه
قبل قليل عشرات العوائل موجوده سواء هنا
او في اماكن اخرى معظمهم من النساء ومن
الاطفال لو انتقلنا الى خارج المسجد سوف
ترون الخيام التي حدثتكم عنها قبل قليل
وهذه الشاحنه الصغيره الان التابعه للدفاع
المدني تقوم بتهيئه المكان المناسب من اجل
وضع الخيام لاستقبال المزيد من العوائل
النازحات حتى الكاميرا في بعض المناطق لم
تصل ولم تذهب الى مناطق بسبب انقطاع
الاتصالات في مناطق عديده شمال غربي سوريا
بعد الزلزال